cette vidéo est sponsorisé par norvez pn
rendez-vous surnommée pay prends ou org
slash cyrus north pour obtenir un
abonnement de deux ans et quatre mois
supplémentaires gratuits avec une énorme
réduction plus d'informations en fin de
vidéo ouvre à tous et bienvenue dans
cette vidéo j'espère que vous allez bien
j'espère que vous avez passé une bonne
semaine j'ai un peu le nez prix et
palmer prix c'est autre chose ah ah est
ce que je voulais vous dire vous
connaissez êtes-vous démerde peut-être
un format si je puis dire juste vos
histoires cette fois ci on va juger vos
histoires on va juger des personnages de
fiction de la série squid des vidéos
sons squeakquel originalité écoutez on a
reçu un mail de youtube qui dit
clairement que si vous êtes youtuber et
que vous faites pas de vidéo sur sweet
games vous risquez de perdre votre titre
de youtube heures voilà qui risque de
devenir un vidéaste re
non moi je suis un vieux tube est ok
alors dans cette vidéo donc on va se
poser les sévères on va ce pôle et on va
sinon sa parentèle donc si vous n'avez
pas vu ce coup de game vous invite à
voile à partir de cette vidéo et je suis
sûr qu'il ya des vidéos que j'ai sorti
vous avions pas regarder ou ok
c'est vrai que c'est un peu fou là ce
succès de squid games pour que même moi
je les regardais c'est que vraiment ça a
plu ça a plu aux gens et là le style
battle royale a toujours fait kiffer
mais la dimension d'inégalités
financière qui s'ajoute elle est
extrêmement contemporaine et donc ça
touche les gens autre chose que j'ai
trouvé intéressant dans cette série
c'est que on se met à la place des gens
donc des participants on à l'anxiété on
a peur pour eux et c est en même temps
on regarde un peu la série comme les
vieilles pies ya ce va et vient entre
observé un petit peu ce que pour les
compétiteurs avec inquiétude et en même
temps observé un peu froidement voilà
des gens qui meurent qui se font éclater
vous savez très bien il ya des persos
voilà on a un peu inquiet il ya les
persos vous connais pas
quand ils crèvent bas on est comme les
vieilles pies pareil je pense que ce qui
a fait que la série marche aussi c'est
qu'il ya plusieurs éléments qui font que
l'aspect un peu horreur terrifiant tout
ça il est très édulcoré édulcoré
oui
[Applaudissements]
on est chaud là on est chaud ouais ouais
on est chauds ouais ouais ouais ya
plusieurs choses qui font ça il ya
toutes les couleurs voilà c'est très
très vive comme série s'est très voilà
une scénographie qui est incroyable et
un côté un peu très instagram abl je
sais pas comment l'expliquer autrement
mais voilà où je pense que je sais ce
que je veux dire on est sur des jeux
d'enfants donc le contraste fait que ben
voila c c - accor qu'un film comme so
par exemple ou c'est pas du tout des
jeux d'enfants et je me demande si le
fait que ce soit en coréen avec un jeu
d'acteur coréens ou sa veille il ya ils
ont ce truc un peu du surjeu voilà y'a
un côté presque théâtre parfois si je me
demande si tout ça ne râle pas une
distance supplémentaire tous ces
éléments distanciation font que la
catharsis est rendu possible la
catharsis d'aristote je vous renvoie
vers cette vidéo que je sorte qu'ils
écoutent et il ya fort fort longtemps
désormais revenons-en au vif du sujet
les paras potes et je connais moins cher
pourquoi tu pars rapporte parce que
relations parent social on va voir un
petit peu les personnages dont on va
parler aujourd'hui saïbi évoque la
nord-coréenne mon amoureuse voilà je
l'appelle la nord coréenne pour vous
mais devant ma télé c'était c'était mon
petit bijou je l'appelais mon petit
bijou je l'appelais mon petit sucre
je suis tombé amoureux des femmes
le vieux tout sans goût le génie sait on
dit groulx
le benêt on va dire abdul ali le gentil
et john cox ou le mafieux
[Musique]
john cox ou c'est très facile un très
facile de savoir si c'est une merde ou
non voilà je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord là dessus c'est il faut aussi
des personnages facile comme ça c'est la
merde par excellence ok
il tue les gens il fout la merde ils les
frappent c'est une sous race le jeu ne
tue pas assez de gens lui dit vas-y je
vais tuer des gens et c'est intéressant
parce que c'est tellement une merde qui
prend toute notre attention ils courront
seront peut-être pas compte des autres
merdes du jeu par zhang dessous
son cas est facile c'est une merde
[Musique]
abdul ali abdul ali là aussi on est sur
un personnage facile qu'est ce qu'il a
fait de merde à 12 il avait des merdes
en dehors du jeu notamment il a volé son
patron et lui a blessé la main etc mais
le patron il était en tort la série nous
le montre le gars qui jouent aux
solitaires j'sais pas quoi pendant qu'on
lui réclame son argent bref il s'emballe
et steak c'est l'argent qui lui était dû
il en avait besoin il a récupéré il est
extrêmement là pour les autres il sauve
par exemple dit woods dans la première
épreuve s'est donné un même d'ailleurs
ou qu'il ait là quoi il est présent sous
on imagine aussi qu'il a un passé
difficile
l'immigration depuis pakistan s'intégrer
en corée du sud voilà c'est peut-être
pas évident malgré ça il est vraiment
tourné vers les autres abdul ali tu n'es
pas une merde
[Musique]
ça est bien souvent un instant oublier à
quel point c'est un petit sucre pour se
concentrer sur le jugement de son
personnage s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît faites cet effort aussi s'il vous
plaît ou alors se souvient que moi je
pense pas la série commence la même
scène pickpockets elle vole jee woon
elle et elle est méchante avec tout le
monde voilà c'est fait la gueule quoi sa
part pour être une mère mais sauf que la
série nous explique aussi pourquoi il
fait ça pourquoi les pickpockets
pourrait vole de l'argent à la lourd
passé elle a fui la corée du nord avec
son frère sa mère est encore là bas elle
essaie de faire sortir sa mère ça lui
coûte des thunes elle a déjà donné
beaucoup d'argent est c'est fait
carottes de ce qu on vous comprend
arnaqueur en fait par les passeurs au
niveau de son comportement dans le jeu
elle est plutôt neutre elle l'aide à un
moment un candidat puisqu'elle est jee
woon sur l'épreuve des verts en lui
rappelant que le premier verre qui est
solide c'est celui de gauche mais en
même temps elle descend le mafieux à 1 2
3 soleil le elle le tir au sol dans ces
mois le fou dans la merde pour moi son
comportement dans le jeu est plutôt
neutre a fait du mieux qu'elle peut avec
dignité et tout ça elle le fait pour sa
famille sincères pour sortir sa mère de
corée du nord et pour sortir son petit
frère d'un foyer pour moi même si ces
actions hors du jeu genre pickpockets
etc même si c'est pas bien son passé son
contexte etc permettent de comprendre
pourquoi le fait et on rajoute à ça son
comportement dans le jeu pour moi elle
n'est pas une merde au delà de ça c'est
un personnage qui a montré beaucoup de
dextérité et franchement j'en veux dire
qu'elle méritait de gagner mais ça l'est
par rapporte c'est un autre sujet
donc dit oui à sa complexe et en même
temps est ce que c'est si complexe que
ça la série un peu nous le dépeint vers
la fin en tout cas comme un mec gentil
quoi il est tellement gentil que il
arrive pas il a du mal à jouer est ce
vraiment la réalité va revenir un peu
sur ce qu'il était hors du jeu mauvais
fils ok le mec qui vit aux crochets de
sa mère et janry il prend de l'argent
dans le dos de sa mère vivre au crochet
ta mère c'est ok si vous faites aussi où
vit au crochet de votre mère enfin je
les fais aussi voilà ce qui n'est pas ok
c'est d'arnaqué sa mère allait prendre
l'argent en douceur et utiliser cet
argent pour jouer au jeu ça c'est nul
c'est un mauvais père par exemple ils
frappent le beau père de sa fille devant
elle il est pas là quand on a besoin de
lui il est même pas qu'elle va de lui
offrir un vrai cadeau d'anniversaire et
a priori c'est un mauvais mari vu le
comportement de sa femme façon extrême 0
contrôle de ses émotions présent vous
souvenez quand ils jouent aux hadjis
chacun leurs cartons et doivent
retourner le carton ou l'autre en le
balançant sur le sol mais il ya un
moment où ils arrivent à gagner et là il
s'apprête à frapper le mec au lieu de
prendre les 10000 hwan park à la base il
avait besoin cet argent donc voilà il
sale type sale type sale type tu le vois
comment il parle aux gens et c'est fin
c'est une merde c'est une merde alors
comment il est dans le bain dans le jeu
aussi c'est une merde 1 malgré ce que la
série veut nous montrer parfois et c'est
le gars il quand même ils arnaquent un
mec qui arrivait et il le manipule avec
alzheimer
comportement de merde est-ce qu ensuite
en sortant du jeu avec toute cette une
on va en profiter pour aller voir sa
fille lui faire du bien et c'est non on
va continuer à être une merde quand même
le moment où il faut prendre l'avion
pour aller voir sa fille enfin à lui
donner peut-être un peu d'amour quoi un
peu la mort de son père qui était absent
bah non bon on va payer on va pas y
aller donc en fait pour moi ce
personnage il est il ya une hypocrisie
autour de lui parce que y
il avance dans le jeu sans se mouiller
sans mettre les mains dans le cambouis
soul et sans avoir de sang sur les mains
quoi le seul moment où il est vraiment
dos au mur et il risque de mourir bah il
fait comme tout le monde c'est à dire
qu' il va manipuler la personne en face
de lui même quand cette personne est
hyper faible voilà donc quelqu'un essaye
murray lui fait croire tout ce qui veut
donc c'est un personnage qui fait quand
même vachement preuve de lâcheté je
trouve donc c'est pas la pire des merdes
donc c'est peut-être la moins pire des
merdes mais pendant ces mères quand même
les trucs gentils à provo lui et ses
tulipes il est pas capable de tuer on
l'a vu notamment à la fin quand il peut
tuer sans coût et il le fait pas il le
ferait seulement s'ils étaient vraiment
dos au mur et c'est ce qu'il a fait un
prêt que le vieux mais en dehors de ça
il a vraiment il l'a pas envie c'est que
le jeu s'arrête alors qu'il a vu sans
coup tu es tout le monde être méchant
machin etc mais non il est trop il est
trop lâche en fait les trois l'âge pour
aller au bout dit pas qu'il aurait dû
débuter mais je dis que la salle acheter
quand même le caractérise le fait qu'ils
prennent aucune responsabilité le
caractérise sauf peut-être vraiment à la
toute fin donc quand même à la toute fin
a priori 16 habilité et clairement
apparemment sa fille n'en fait pas
partie donc j'ai du mal avec ce perso
pour moi c'est une merde
[Musique]
chevaux sans goût
a priori c'est la plus grosse merde mais
pourtant quand on creuse je trouve que
c'est pas si évident que ça en fait pour
moi il ya 200 goût qui sont assez
distincts celui dont on se souvient
c'est celui qui tue des gens qui tuent
des gens qui parfois l'ont aidé et qui
ne pense vraiment que je pense qu'à lui
dans le jeu voilà qui à cet égoïsme
caractéristiques des merdes finalement
mais un s'en fout du début je sais pas
si vous en souvenez déjà ils l'aident
dit woods pendant le 1 2 3 soleil il lui
dit ouais et 7 mètres derrière quelqu'un
si tu restes comme ça tu vas mourir
voilà donc il prend des risques en
l'aidant potentiellement en bougeant et
c'est à un moment où en fait on se rend
compte qu'en fait les gens créent avec
ses dons qu'il aurait pu paniquer il
aurait pu rester sur son truc mais non
il a aidé du couvent à ce moment là et
c'est lui qui organise le vote pour
potentiellement se barrait de ce truc
c'est lui qui dit ok les gars c'est pas
possible je me souviens qu'ils avaient
cette règle là et c'est lui qui lance le
truc a priori sera mec bien mais qu'est
ce qui se passe pourquoi il ya 200 goût
qu'est ce qui a entre les deux entre le
deuxième tentative de suicide sans vous
il veut ce but est donc en fait le sang
vous qui revient dans le jeu il est déjà
mort à l'intérieur sous l'île a plus
rien à perdre j'ai le prouver son goût
qui quelque part n'est pas vraiment une
merde après voilà il atteint même mis en
jeu les propriétés de sa mère etc enfin
quelque part si on part là dedans c'est
un peu tous des merdes mais son
comportement pendant le jeu son entraide
et le fait qu'il ait pris la parole pour
défendre un peu tout le monde toute la
communauté lancé ce vote et compagnie
pour moi ça le fait pencher un peu du
côté la balance pagne noir le deuxième
sans goût comme je disais il est mort à
l'intérieur et du coup il n'a plus rien
à perdre et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'ils se suicident à la fin parce qu'en
fait la seule chose qui compte à ce
moment là pour lui c'est de sortir sa
mère de sa situation et qui sait que
s'il n'y a pas de gagnant elle sortira
pas de cette situation donc ils
préfèrent mourir et que sa mère sorte de
la tuque sortir vivants et d'où le fait
d'ailleurs que quand il est en train de
crever les mots qu'il donne à ji woon
c'est à chaque fois genre ma mère ma
mère etc on imagine qu'il est qui dit un
truc genre en soi ma mère ou
de l'argent à ma mère ou school encore
une fois si on garde la plupart des
épreuves si jee woon gagne c'est en
grande partie grâce à son goût sauf pour
l'épreuve du parapluie étoiles car un
triangle tout ça le 1 2 3 soleil il aide
le fait de tirer à la corde il sauve
l'équipe au niveau des vitres on sait
pas y avait une chance sur deux qui se
plante mais vu qu'il a poussé le gars
bon bah au moins on avait résultat peut
tenir à ce moment là johnny il s'en
serait sorti quoiqu'il à n'en pas
quoiqu'il parce que toi sont le timer
est en train de terminer et les sorties
du jeu in extremis en fait j'avoue 600
coups avaient attendu avant de pousser
le gars peut-être que dis je vous n'aura
pas survécu et à la fin le squeeze game
où il se tue donc si jy yoon gagne c'est
très souvent grâce à son coup et même
avec son suicide il offre une porte de
sortie hyper simple hadj ou sans
culpabilité ou en tout cas le moins
possible et donc il sauve sa mère est ce
que c'est une merde ou est ce que au
final il l'a fait juste simplement jouer
au jeu je pense que ça reste une merde
mais je trouve que remettre les choses
en perspective sur son histoire complète
voir à quel point ces actions ont
bénéficié aux autres ça permet de l'un
peut contrebalancer son statut en fait
sont son statut de merde est étroitement
lié à celui de bwin je trouve parce que
ce serait injuste que ji woon ne soit
pas une merde parce que son goût l'a été
et qu'en fait j'ai on a juste profité du
fait que son goût a été merde et donc
abattu voûté pas une merde sans vous
aimez c'est un peu trop simple pour moi
leur destin quelque part sont liées
parce que les actions de l'un ou de
telles répercussions sur les actions de
l'autre et la balance penche quand même
sur le fait que son goût et peut-être
qu'ils quelque part je suis un peu
provocateur ici je ne sais pas mais ce
soit pas une énorme mais malgré ce que
la série veut nous faire penser
[Musique]
enfin dernier personnage aux îles nam le
vieux c'est l'organisateur de tout ce
cirque 1 c'est le le plat twist de la
série à moi j'avais grillé pas du tout
oui c'est horrible et a priori c'est une
énorme merde faut bien appeler un truc
ce qui laisse aux participants le choix
et le fait que ce soit le dernier a voté
il pourrait très bien voter voisine en
reste mais ils votent vas-y ça s'arrête
et je vous laisse revenir de votre plein
gré si vous en avez envie donc lui créé
juste une possibilité y créer une option
elle est horrible cette option elle est
détestable mais il la met juste sur la
table quelque part et en plus de ça
chaque année il prend quelqu'un qui est
dans la misère et laurent immensément
riche vous pourriez me dire c'est une
merde parce que il prend plaisir à
regarder ces chants s'entretuer
peut-être
et vous dans ce cas là
on a pris le même plaisir
n'est-ce pas soudainement notre destin
est lié à lui
fiction est on peut on peut faire des
expériences de pensée un peu on peut
filer ça fait un peu ou pas c'est
difficile de pas le mettre dans la
catégorie merde parce que vous mais ils
n'ont rien fait à une organisation
tu vois tout çà c'est prémédité c'est il
ya eu d enlèvement aussi tu vas me
lauria les a menés là au début raconte
le jir pensais même pas en fait les
enlèvement il leur donne un rendez vous
les gars viennent de leur plein gré et
comment il les fait venir de leur plein
gré il leur propose un jeu le jeu du dag
j ai donc les gars viennent de leur
plein gré aussi à chaque fois qu'ils
appellent je me tiens prêt aussi de
traduction sarko fait vu que j'aime
regarder enfin je parle pas coréen et
j'ai du mal à savoir genre le mot
éliminé en français il ya un peu ce
double sens doit être éliminé éliminé
gens mourir mais il est vraiment très
qu'il est vraiment bourdin observe que
c'est qu'on te dis ouais on va jouer un
jeu tu vas être éliminé je m'attends pas
à mourir quoi vraiment mais je me
demande encore et 1 c'était quoi ce mot
parce que si c'est aussi vagues que
éliminés pour moi le but est une merde
et je pense que c'est le cas parce que
vu la surprise qu'a le joueur qui est
derrière le premier qui se fait buter
les modes à ok on peut mourir donc c'est
là où pour moi ça c'est cet élément là
qui fait que moi c'est sûr que c'est une
merde ohlins que c'était pas dit
d'emblée clairement qu'aucun va joindre
deux trois soleil
si vous perdez ou vous mourrez genre
vous butez même fallait le dire dès le
dj quoi deldalle j'y vois là on n'a rien
dit des jeux bon vous pouvez laisser
votre peau mais par contre vous pouvez
gagner beaucoup d'argent voilà un souci
de franchement s'il avait été honnête et
franc hyper transparent du début à la
fin j'aurais eu du mal à dire que c'est
une merde je crois c'est totalement
illégal c'est vraiment
ethiquement c'est pas possible et ceara
et en même temps voilà si le gars est
juste il est transparent il donne une
option et les gens saisissent l'option
je sais pas je sais pas à la question se
pose j'espère que cette attendez quoi
j'ai bien un personnage apparemment
et sénart bpm et
c6 roasters
bnf vous savez pas ce que c'est un
réseau privé virtuel à quoi ça sert
c'est très simple à quoi ça sert ça sert
à pouvoir sécurisé et chiffré votre
connexion notamment lorsque vous êtes
sur des connexions qui ne sont pas
chiffrés pas sécurisé par exemple vous
êtes à un café un fast food et c'est à
vous êtes sur le wi fi publics et vous
aller sur des sites qui sont pas en
https on pourrait lire toutes vos
transactions
avec un vpn non ces chiffres et moi
j'utilise dans ces cas-là mais j'utilise
aussi dans un autre cas de figure c'est
lorsque je veux faire croire au monde
entier que je suis ailleurs avec un vpn
vous pouvez vous connecter de n'importe
où dans le monde et donc ça sert à plein
de choses ça sert à accéder à des sites
qui sont pas forcément accessibles là où
vous avez ça sert aussi par exemple sans
date fixe à voir du catalogue qui n'est
pas dans votre pays par exemple vous
voulez voir tout le catalogue de la
corée du sud et bien sûr le vpn ou
connecter depuis la corée du sud une
fois vous avez votre conteneur de peine
ou pour le mettre sur plusieurs
appareils que ce soit l'ordinateur que
ce soit le téléphone que ce soit la
tablette ça marche hyper facilement
c'est hyper rapide c'est hyper
accessible c'est fiable et on apprécie
en maintenant la question qui se pose
c'est comment la voir comment avoir
denrées pn c'est très simple vous êtes
sûr nord de pn point org slash cyrus
noir pourquoi aller sur ce site et parce
que vous avez une énorme réduction vous
prenez un abonnement de deux ans vous
avez quatre mois ou faire autre chose
très important s'est satisfait ou
remboursé pendant 30 jours vous pouvez
très bien les ayez voir ce que ça donne
vous voir si vous êtes à l'aise avec
vous faire rembourser si ça vous plait
pas je les remercie et est sponsor
quasiment à l'année sous mes vidéos et
j'espère que vous y trouverez un intérêt
vous aussi des vidéos touche à sa fin
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu dit moi
aussi si vous qui fait ce genre de
concept de se demander si des
personnages de fiction sont des merdes
vous avoue que j'avais eue
l'idée des personnages de fiction avant
ce coup de game me dira de faire
etes-vous démerde spéciale sur certains
personnages de fiction est en fait là
avec la sortie de squeez kerry killinger
d'en parler en vidéo et c'était du pain
béni voilà mais dites moi si c'est un
truc qui vous intéresse et voudront à
coup ou non en masse très très fort
jeudi à la semaine prochaine love peace
ciao
[Musique]